on March 27 Thea canopy presented its  annual scientific or technical Awards  Oscar winner Shirley Jones presented  special Oscars to John Pospisil and  Stephen flick the men responsible for  the extraordinary sound effects editing  in Robocop an Oscar also went to the  osram corporation for their development  of the system that's changed the way  that sets are lit from Iceland to  Australia Samuel Goldwyn jr. presented  the Gordon East  Sawyer / Lifetime Achievement Award to  master sound technician Fred Heinz what  is it I'm not you're touching my ear and  the suit visit him  here sorry  our fifth nominated best picture  involves a love triangle it's a comic  story of a manic young female news  producer and her relationships with the  handsome anchorman she pushes to the top  of his game and then out of her life and  into the Ernests and the earnest  reporter who finds out the hard way that  when the heat is on he sweats  it's called broadcast news